ancien conseiller spécial de nicolas
sarkozy à l'elysée député ump des
yvelines henri guaino est notre invité
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous à ce
rendez-vous de preuves par 3 avec l'
agence france-presse
et dailymotion avec dans un instant donc
perrine tarneaud et puis nadège peljak
de la fp vous êtes avec nous dans cet
entre-deux en quelque sorte un entre la
nomination l'arrivée de manuel valls à
matignon après la déroute électorale du
ps aux élections municipales et puis il
annonce un gouvernement de combat un
gouvernement resserré comme l'a annoncé
françois hollande
d'abord est-ce que vous souhaiter bonne
chance à manuel valls qui ouvre donc
l'acte 2 du quinquennat
est ce que vous le souhaitez de réussir
bien sûr comment ne pas souhaiter au
gouvernement de mon pays de réussir
maintenant j'ai des doutes sur sur sa
capacité à répondre aux défis auxquels
il se trouve confronté après les
élections de dimanche dernier dix
manches précédentes des jeux sur sa
personne
non non des doutes parlant de lui un peu
oui c'est qu'il a de meilleur à tôt par
exemple que jean marc ayrault pris les
traits il est différent mais c'est pas
le premier ministre qui fait la
politique de la france c'est le
président de la république
donc on va on va voir ce que ce que ce
tandem areeba à faire ma phase iib gens
si j'en juge par l'allocution du
président de la république hier soir le
défi n'est pas près d'être relevé l'idée
la feuille de route c'est aller plus
vite et plus loin et toujours poursuivre
le redressement oui ce qu'a dit
d'ailleurs se valent aujourd'hui il a
dit on continue et on amplifie bon si
c'est ça la réponse au message compte
envoyer les français au cours des deux
tours des élections municipales
je comprends qu'il y est un profond
malentendu les français ont dit ça peut
pas continuer comme ça et on change de
premier ministre levant disant ça
continue voilà je pense que ça va pas
très bien finir 6
le gouvernement et le président la
république restent sur 7 sur cette ligne
de conduite
et si vous avez remarqué que le peuple
français étaient en colère si vous ne
l'avez pas vu renvoyer le résultat des
élections
une immense abstention qui n'est pas une
abstention d'indifférence mais de rejet
une montée des extrêmes qui est tout de
même extrêmement inquiétante et qui est
très forte
cette colère elle ne peut pas ne pas
rester contenue si on répond à un peuple
qui dit changer tout on continue
alors tout va bien compris la leçon et
les premiers visés bien sûr d'abord on a
entendu françois hollande reconnaître
que le message était fort et aujourd'hui
même manuel valls dit qu'il a entendu de
la part du peuple français comme vous
dites rien une demande de justice
sociale non si on est homo ça ce sont
des mots il est moi je retiens il a dit
on continue et on amplifie voilà on
continue et on amplifie les mots 10
gbits/s qui veut le dire à dire qu'on
continue comme avant parce que vous ne
vous fait les s'était pas venir - comme
jean pierre raffarin par exemple qui dit
qu'avec manuel valls et françois
hollande la plus choisie la droite que
la gauche que la gauche que de la gauche
- le mot la droite à gauche la gauche de
la droite et gauche de la gauche comme
ça m'intéresse pas je ça n'intéresse
personne d'ailleurs
un personne c'est une ligne peut-être
une incarnation n'est pas tout à fait la
même avec un personnage comme manuel
valls n'est nommé daniël a été fixé hier
par le président de la république vous
avez écouté son discours
si monsieur valls a compris ce que le
président attendait nuit tant mieux
parce que moi je n'ai rien compris entre
le président hier et manuel valls
aujourd'hui la seule chose qu'on peut
retenir c'est qu'en gros continuent et
que simplement on va servir un peu plus
de clientèle ici ou là on va donner un
peu plus aux un peu moins aux autres
voilà ça sans savoir d'ailleurs comment
on va financer ce qu'on m'a donné
sans voir où est la ligne où est la
cohérence on est toujours confronté au
même problème depuis le début de ce
quinquennat et il n'y a pas de ligne il
n'y a pas de cap
mais on 10 ans a rien qu'on maintient le
cap mais quelques apps
vous savez si tous les marins du monde
depuis le début des temps avec la même
définition du cap
je pense que il tournera iraient
beaucoup de bateaux qui tournerait
encore au milieu de l'océan depuis des
six mois tandis que romain est lui-même
en quelque sorte c'est ça mais oui mais
cette somme dans la vème république et
avec le quinquennat donc avec le
quinquennat le président fait tout ou
presque tout donc si le président ne
change pas ne se réforme pas lui même
espace rire mais néanmoins avec la
personnalité forte de manuel valls est
ce que on peut s'interroger sur la
nature de la cohabitation avec le
mondial entre les nations ça c'est à
langlade explique alain vème république
il ya pas de cohabitation dans la vème
république c'est le président qui décide
c'est le président qui est la clé de
voûte des institutions
c'est le président qui est l'élu du
peuple donc c'est le c'est l'homme de la
nation
y'a pas de cohabitation il n'y a aucune
espèce d'égalité ni de rivalité une
concurrence possible et quand il en est
une où quand un premier ministre à la
velléité de on entre en concurrence avec
le président de la république ça finit
toujours de la même manière le premier
s'en va rappelez-vous jacques
chaban-delmas rappelez-vous jacques
chirac
rappelez-vous michel rocard voilà c'est
mais les choses se passent toujours de
cette façon déjà écrit là puisque j'ai
entendu hier soir et est aujourd'hui
l'avenir me paraît déjà écrit mais
l'avenir c'est pas à l'avenir entre les
deux hommes c'est l'avenir entre le
président de la république et son
gouvernement et sa majorité et le peuple
et le peuple français et allemands quand
même sur sur manuel valls que je me
souviens que nicolas sarkozy avait ou
aurait alors à l'époque proposait une
ouverture vers manuel valls recrutement
éventuellement de manuel valls dans le
cadre de verdure
je vous pose la question c'est que vous
pouvez confirmer jusqu'à maintenant voir
l'intérêt qu'elle a pu ceci je ne
confirme rien du tout madame j'ai de
l'estimé pour manuel valls mais je pense
qu'ils la mission qui lui est confiée
est aujourd'hui une mission impossible
alors je n'observe mission impossible
d'abord aucun aucun premier ministre
sitôt nommé n'a suscité autant de
critiquer dans les dix ans dans sa
propre majorité
bon monsieur mamère a eu même cette
formule et disait de monsieur valls
était pas le plus grand rassembleur mais
plus grand diviseur de la gauche
bon alors je suis bien avec mêlant chant
lundi charge plein champ de la 10e aussi
mais beaucoup d'autres l'ont dit
certains publics d'autres à mots
couverts je suis bien certain qu'il aura
une majorité au parlement
s'ils posent la question de confiance je
suis bien certain que il arrivera à
faire entrer au gouvernement
probablement toutes les composantes
qu'il souhaite de sa majorité
c'est une question de prix le problème
le problème est de savoir ce qu'il est
prêt à faire comme concession à tous
ceux qui dans la majorité sont en
désaccord avec lui ou en tout cas ne
voulait pas de lui qu'on fait tout lui
demander d'être lui-même a tempéré vous
saluer mais non c'est un saint cyp si
pour être acceptable par tout le monde
si pour arriver à rassembler tant bien
que mal et plutôt mal que bien la
majorité il
et fait des concessions extravagantes je
pense pas que ça va améliorer la
situation à leur gouvernement la
situation due justement pour préserver
la majorité présidentielle actuelle
manuel valls a très tôt consulter
rencontrer les responsables d'europe
écologie les verts on sait que cécile
duflot ee pascal canfin ne feront pas du
parti du gouvernement en raison d'un
problème de ligne on til dit néanmoins
il ya des avancées qui se dessine avec
l'entrée probable de personnalités que
je ressente la tentation tentation est
forte c'est certain
si on puisse qu'on leur offre beaucoup
la tentation est encore plus forte
bon mais est il bien raisonnable
honnêtement de confier aux écologistes
si j'en crois ce que j'entends à la
radio et à la télévision
un grand ministère regroupant l'écologie
les transports l'énergie
voilà jusqu'où iront les concessions de
monsieur valls à la gauche de la gauche
du parti socialiste aux écologistes
voilà jusqu'où jusqu'où ira-t-il c'est
quand même une vraie une vraie question
ce soir
alors selon pascal canfin cécile du tout
se serait vu proposer le poste de numéro
deux du gouvernement justement pour
qu'elle reste un jeu pense que la
meilleure solution aurait été de le
nommer premier ministre non pourquoi pas
on sépare chaque été fait par le
gendarme marié l'anc a donné tant que
tant qu'à distribuer les postes de cette
façon c'est le problème du président de
la république de cette majorité
le président de la république est un
homme de la quatrième république c'est
un homme qui ne sait pas gouverner
autrement qu'en marchant dans avec les
uns et les autres
donc il sert des clientèles il sert d il
se comporte comme le premier secrétaire
du parti socialiste avec les courants
les sous-courants les sensibilités
diverses du parti socialiste se
rassembler ensemble est une chose faire
du clientélisme en est une tout autre et
lui fait du clientélisme
il est le produit spectre du parti
socialiste oui il serre les clientèles
dans la société
les minorités agissantes et communautés
tout le monde à tout le monde a sa part
et puis dans le dans la façon de gérer
la majorité et le gouvernement il le
fait comme faisait le premier comme il
le faisait quand il était premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste françois
mitterrand avait compris que y avait une
différence entre la fonction
présidentielle et celle de premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste
mais manifestement ça n'est pas encore
le cas de françois hollande mais on peut
pas peut pas gouverner comme ça pourquoi
il tente de couacs dans le précédent
gouvernement
pas simplement parce que monsieur
ayrault aurait manqué d'autorité mais
parce que monsieur ayrault était fait
d'ailleurs sur le même modèle que
monsieur que monsieur hollande c'est 100
m de la quatrième république
chaque ministre chaque ministre avait le
sentiment d'être le porte parole de la
clientèle est un homme de la quatrième
république
non je crois pas que ce soit l'homme de
la quatrième république mais il entre
dans un système où l'impulsion la ligne
la politique sont définis par le chef de
l'état et le chef de l'état est un homme
bien catherine fmi craignant une
révision à la baisse du pacte de
compétitivité pour les entreprises non
mais moi je sais toujours pas ce qui va
sortir donc on verra quand ça sortira ça
ne ressemblera sûrement rien à ce que le
président de la république avait promis
voilà lancés comme d'habitude
bon alors il y aura pas de duras pas de
contrepartie parce que c'était farfelue
mais ça veut dire que le président avait
raconté n'importe quoi mais plus vite
plus loin ou ou et est ce que les
français on dit aller plus vite plus
loin en continuant exactement ce qu'on
faisait je moi je ne sais pas je sais
pas quelle est la stratégie du
gouvernement je ne sais pas quelle est
sa politique économique
un jouet dans l'atlantique de la demande
on supprime toutes les exonérations de
charge tous les allègements c'était le
lendemain dans la politique de l'offre
et puis le surlendemain on se dit
peut-être qu'il faut revenir à la
demande et l'économie ça se fait avec
l'offre et la demande où est la
stratégie d'offre et de demande où est
la politique macroéconomique du
gouvernement je n'en sais rien personne
n'en sait rien mais c'est bien c'est
bien le problème
il n'y a toujours pas de cap nous
appartenait à parler un parti qui
préconise plus de 100 milliards à
écouter vous n'avez pas invité mon parti
moi on m'avait invité moi oui voilà donc
il ya des gens d'alors alors je suis
profondément lui même profondément lors
du salon réservé aux employés aux 50
milliards d'euros bien même aucune je ne
crois pas aux 50 milliards d'euros
et je crois pas non plus de 100
milliards d'euros je n'en ai pas si je
pense que c'est nous sommes nous sommes
dans une forme enfermé dans une façon
d'aborder l'économie qui est sans issue
voilà sans issue pourquoi parce que la
finance publique ne se rétabliront pas
en faisant en comparant n'importe
comment dans les dépenses du jour au
lendemain d'ailleurs c'est impossible
personne ne l'a ni a réussi et quand on
fait à n'importe quel prix ça fait de
tels dégâts que de toute façon ça cause
des déficits bon et donc nous nous
rétablirons nos finances publiques
si nous comprenons enfin que les l'état
nos finances publiques et le résultat la
conséquence de ce qui se passe dans
l'économie et dans la société
c'est en me remettant de l'ordre dans
l'économie et dans la société que nous
alors on assigne un dauphiné ramic
d'accord ma dernière question en lien
avec le gouvernement c'est vraiment fait
une des politiques d'austérité les pires
depuis le début de la vème république
avec les résultats que l'on sait c'est à
dire qu'on n'arrive pas à maîtriser les
déficits n'arrive même pas à maîtriser
la dépense tout en faisant une politique
d'austérité
on est enfermé dans dcuo justement
terrible vous avez dit ce que vous
pensez de le maintien éventuel de lune
ministre écologique dans le gouvernement
henri guaino est-ce que vous souhaiter
le maintien par exemple sur laquelle
vous pouvez avoir des positions communes
en parler postérité le rhône estime pour
andres bourg mais je suis pas en train
de moi je ne suis pas habilité
bien sûr à baba pour céder la disto
river a commenté aussi non non ne suis
pas un commentateur de la vie poétique
c'est le président de la république qui
choisit son gouvernement c'est lui qui
nomme le premier ministre et chacun des
ministres individuellement c'est le
président de la république qui en décide
c'est son choix voilà il décide
je n'ai moi je n'ai pas de commentaire à
faire sauf que je constate que pour
l'instant il n'y a aucune réponse au
changement demandé avec force par des
français très bien voilà on a bien
compris le message de cette première
partie d'émission a ajouté kim a
beaucoup beaucoup celui de choses qui
m'ont choqué hier la façon dont s'est
passée l'annoncent delà de la démission
de monsieur ayrault et de la nomination
de monsieur valls c'est contre c'est
contraire à tous les usages de la vème
république il ya bien des ordres dans
les institutions qui devient et ça monte
ça monte inquiétant aujourd'hui
moi j'ai trouvé curieux que monsieur
valls pour pour ses premiers mots à la
nation en tant que premier ministre je
suis socialiste ou sommes socialistes et
un premier mini s'il n'est pas
socialiste
il n'est pas de droite il n'est pas de
gauche il est premier ministre tous les
français et pour la république et un
comme monsieur valls ça me surprend
beaucoup et ça m'inquiète un peu pour
l'avenir voilà je crois que si on si on
est décidé à gouverner en dressant une
france de golf contre une france de
droite une france socialiste contre une
france qui montre l'engagement quand on
est pour les mineurs un seul un seul
c'est un engagement vis-à-vis de la
france
et pareil pour le président de la
république aurait pas socialiste où tout
le monde connaît l'histoire de monsieur
valls ou le cône et celle de monsieur de
monsieur hollande y a pas besoin de
rappeler l'appartenance à un parti et on
a compris votre message principal de ce
premier quart d'heure de l'émission et
guaino pour vous c'est mission
impossible pour ce nouveau duo de
l'exécutif nadège plus chaste ça va très
dur promotionnelle seul et ça c'est sûr
nadège jack guez afp arrive donc nous
allons maintenant évoquer la situation à
l'ump excuse après la vague bleue on a
noté chez certains de vos amis
d'ailleurs une manière de réserve pas
triomphalisme à votre sanction pour
françois hollande est il synonyme de
victoire par défaut pour l'opposition
faustine saint geniès au groupe ump du
sénat ce matin
on savoure la victoire on se félicite et
on espère repartir sur de bonnes bases
labatt bleue serait elle un remède de
choc pour faire oublier les conflits à
l'ump
c'est une victoire éclatante le mp se
porte bien malgré tout le bashing comme
on dit aujourd'hui tous les jours tous
les jours tous les jours c'était en
miettes
eh bien non le grand gagnant de ces
municipales c'est bien sûr jean françois
copé lui qui il ya encore quinze jours
et est empêtrée dans l'affairé bygmalion
il aimerait bien surfer sur la vague
bleue et réduire ses rivaux au silence
au moins dans l'immédiat
de son côté françois fillon avait promis
de lui demander des comptes
il a tenu parole et vient de réclamer
plus de transparence à l'ump l'ump où
l'on préfère éviter de rouvrir les
plaies pour se concentrer sur les enjeux
de l'élection
je pense que d'une part l'unité de la
direction de l'ump dans ce contexte qui
n'était pas facile a été assumée par
tous dans tous nos meetings dans de
nombreuses réunions communes mais aussi
une certaine forme de sobriété
on n'a pas triomphé on a conscience de
la gravité dans le camp de jean françois
copé
on met en garde les éventuels fauteurs
de troubles nous avons largement gagné
ni nos élus ni nos militants nos
électeurs ne veulent aujourd'hui du sang
à l'ump ce qu'ils peuvent venir
protester contesté critiqué vont
apparaître comme mauvais joueur et comme
hors du cadre
et nous le dirons clairement une ump qui
veut donc apparaître uni en vue des
prochaines échéances sénatoriales en
2014 et régionales en 2015
ces résultats on a vu conforte le
président de votre parti jean françois
copé
elle voit un gars des chefs se terminer
alors à vous dire que la guerre des
chefs soient terminés je l'espère je
l'espère je suis pas sûr que cette cette
municipale va permettre d'enterrer tout
les haches de guerre il
les querelles d'ego des ambitions il
faut rappeler vous tel parti socialiste
à la même époque
après la défaite de 2007 après tout la
politique vous savez c'est humain ça se
fait avec avec des gens qui ont des
sentiments qui ont des ambitions mais à
votre avis qui tire le plus de profit de
cette victoire
nicolas sarkozy puisqu'il faut s'y
emparer nicolas sarkozy voilà justement
fois qu'il les reçoit en tous les cas
killer qui les a pas mais monsieur
guaino va sans doute nous l'expliqué
jean-françois copé juppé françois fillon
et puis on peut aussi citer laurent
wauquiez a brillamment réélu lui aussi
au puy en velay xavier bertrand est
aussi réélue
bruno le maire baroin françois baroin a
lui aussi
alors à qui ça profite mais à tous ceux
qui ont été élus voilà ils ont été élus
ou réélus bravo
est ce que jean françois copé est plus
que jamais le chef de l'opposition n'y a
pas de chef de l'opposition
il épate haye a pas de charme n'y a pas
de chef de l'opposition on sait que ça a
beaucoup déplaire à monsieur max elle
n'a pas ce monsieur sarkozy nous dire ah
ça non pas parce qu'il y avait un chef
cet intérêt c'est ce que tu vois les
noms des chefs ça se décrète pas il sait
pas non plus de gagner
il ya un président de l'ump il n'est pas
contesté dans sa fonction aujourd'hui ça
fait pas ça fait pas le chef ou alors il
y en a une multitude tout le monde est
chef de lui même face et qu'est ce qui
fait la différence entre un copé est un
sarkozy parents qu'est ce qui fait
monsieur sarkozy était un chef blessé
c'est inné c'est la mystérieuse chimie
du charisme et du chef voilà il ya de
temps en temps émergent quelqu'un qui
s'impose à tous les autres et qui est
capable d'entraîner tout le monde de
faire la synthèse de surmonter les
contradictions
d'haïti qui a quelqu'un qui a acquis une
légitimité qui apparaît comme évidente à
tout le monde c'était le cas ça a été le
cas pour nicolas sarkozy
pour l'instant il a laissé un grand vide
en partant ce vide n'est pas remplie
salé faire injure à personne que de le
constater
est-ce que lui parce que lui fillon
monsieur juppé à monsieur bertrand il ya
tous les autres s'ils ont un chef et pas
plus à monsieur copé d'ailleurs y'a pas
de chef
bon alors il n'y a pas de chef alors
qu'est ce qui va se passer en 2010 c'est
parce que on voit déjà dans les starting
blocks un autre parti pour 2017
on prend on parle de préparer
l'alternance c'est un mot qui a été
employé par le super par monsieur copé
par monsieur fillon tout le monde veut
préparer l'alternance chez vous bon ça
non mais c'est normal ce mardi c est ce
qui nous mène à 2017 nous fait
évidemment penser au président à
l'ancien président pardon à l'ancien
président nicolas sarkozy et donc aux
primaires parce qu'il faudra bien
départager tout ce petit monde bien sûr
contre la primaire la caisse des métiers
contre la primaire
la question est là alors qu'est-ce que
vous attaquez ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui il faut une primaire qu'est
ce qui va se passer parce que moi je
suis contre le principe des primaires
qui est totalement contradictoire avec
les principes de la vème république
non non c'est maintenant avec maintenant
parce que la démocratie c'est d'aller
devant le peuple
il ya une élection présidentielle à deux
tours qui se fait qui est qui qui permet
au président de la république d'être
l'élu de la nation la démocratie c'est
ça le reste ce sont les affaires des
partis bon ou des camps mais où la
démocratie avec deux tours d'élection
elle est parfaitement respectée là son
compte démocratie c'est pas en faisant
quatre tours en rajoutant deux tours de
primaires au 2 tour des présidentielles
qu'on est plus démocratique ou alors il
n'y a pas de grandes démocraties dans le
monde parce que ce sera c'est le seul
pays au monde à 4,34 tout quatre tours
d'élection le seul
voilà ce qui se passe d'ailleurs
simplement tout le monde a voulu des
primaires il y aura donc des primaires à
l'exception de
dans le cas où nicolas sarkozy
déciderait parce que les circonstances
l'exigent parce que les français ont le
sentiment que les français ont besoin de
lui
déciderait de se représenter voilà moi
je n'imagine pas un instant nicolas
sarkozy passant par l'étape des
primaires pour se présenter devant les
français
si il veut se présenter il se présente
dirais que fillon va laisser faire ça
ils vont laisser classement vous croyez
vraiment que que tout ceci a une
importance quelconque
voilà donc vous croyez vraiment monsieur
fillon qui ancien premier ministre
monsieur copé qui est président de l'ump
n'a pas d'importance avant d'annoncer sa
dépense et monsieur sarkozy à mes yeux
ne peut pas passer par la case des
primaires donc à mes yeux
il décide de se représenter il ira
directement devant les français dira
voilà je suis candidat en voilà les
raisons en voici les raisons et gmt
l'euro à déterminer pour savoir si elle
ne soutient pas et je peux vous faire un
pari c'est qu'elle ne soutiendra et
renoncera la procédure des primaires
mais cette question ne se posera même
pas à metz et à la pause aujourd'hui à
deux ronds ils apposeront les attendront
la réponse très longtemps la réponse
elle deviendra des blés temps des
adhérents en a qui diront mais moi je
trouve que la démocratie c'est de cette
affaire enfin c'est une blague
mira de la démocratie vous verrez que la
prière soit le signe infaillible de la
démocratie oui c'est une blague
est-ce que vous pensez que tous les
éléments tout l'évolution de la
situation que vous avez n'est que manuel
valls était dans une mission impossible
vont forcément conduire une envie une
décision candidature de nicolas je ne
ressens rien mais j'y reviens il ne s'y
serait une serait pas beau s'il décide
d'être candidat qui l'aï sans commencer
par s'enfermer dans son camp c'est tout
problème des primaires bon on a décidé
de les faire encore une fois à
l'exception de sa candidature s'il n'est
pas candidat on les fera mais ça oblige
les gens à s'enfermer dans leur temps ça
les oblige à se durcir
ça nous oblige à se fermer aux autres et
le président de la république c'est tout
le contraire
d'ailleurs on oublie toujours le cas de
monsieur hollande regarde et il a été
élu c'est fantastique ça a permis de
sélectionner le pire président de la
vème république a encore une fois encore
une fois le celui c'est même pire le
pire le pire doit pour l'instant c'est
le pire on n'a pas fait pire seulement
je n'ai jamais vu pire jamais vu le pays
dans un état pareil si vous avez un
exemple depuis cinquante-huit d'une
situation pareille où les français sont
autant divisé où tout s'effondre ou les
institutions elles-mêmes sont ébranlées
alors dites moi quelle période
quel moment quel moment de notre
histoire depuis 58 à dire depuis le
moment où grâce au général de gaulle on
a évité de sombrer dans la guerre civile
expliquez moi quand on a vu on assiste à
une situation pareille
un tel naufrage
politique institutionnel économique
sociale sociétale puisque c'est d'avoir
un cours commun un possible sauveur si
je puis employé ce mot là je sais pas si
c'est un sauveur mais peut-être qu'à un
certain moment il apparaîtra beaucoup de
français que c'est une solution mais
nous verrons les circonstances en
décideront et lui-même prendra sa
décision et le moment venu ils vous en
voulez vous en forme on voulait parler
qu'est-ce qu'il vous dit oui mais vous
savez j'ai un principe respecter celles
qui ont dit ça je ne parle jamais du
contenu de mes conversations et qui
connaissent alors c'est à propos de
recours il ya peu perdu car je n'aime
plus jacques comme je n'ai pas
l'habitude de les enregistrer pour les
rendre publiques
attention certains peuvent le faire à
roodepoort envie voilà donc double
raison 1 pour garder dans l'intimité ce
qui relève de l'intimité
oui jamais et vous ne seront pas de
recours monsieur juppé se place lui-même
comme un recours bien sûr j'ai entendu
dire qu'on n'était pas en 2017 et ce
n'était pas le moment
écoutant on va déjà branché très vous
poser une question aux part souvent dans
la presse
monsieur manuel valls qui est maintenant
premier ministre à nicolas sarkozy c'est
d'ailleurs là une demain de charlie
hebdo
on a une belle caricature de manuel
valls avec comme légende
et bien voilà sarkozy est à matignon et
vous qui est resté proche de l'ancien
président ça vous énerve ça me flatte
d'une comparaison aux autres flottes ne
met jamais je ne m'étais pas rendu
compte que sarkozy était en train de
mettre leur nom souvent à ce point ils
sont dynamiques tous les deux parce que
ils ont apprécié d'être dynamique
universo ximité et biologique c'est
parfois même je sais plus grand bien aux
c'est ce que nicolas sarkozy a porté
comme comme une idée comme principe
lorsqu'il a fait comme politique
comment il a affronté les épreuves du
pouvoir et de la crise pour l'instant on
ne sait pas comment
manuel valls se comporterait dans des
circonstances analogues et dans 10
et la place qu'occupe et nicolas sarkozy
se rappelle qu' il est rentré à l'hôtel
matignon par l'elysée aujourd'hui nous
verrons mais moi je moi je trouve les
deux hommes très dissemblables même si
il ya chez manuel valls une énergie
volonté et une ambition
oui m'enfin soit leur mission vous savez
c'est la chose la mieux partagée du mlm
a toujours affirmé oum souvent très
affirmée la wii est bon pour en revenir
à l'ump ce matin photos sexy et au petit
déjeuner ce week end alors peut-être que
dans le vert entendu parler de la
demande de monsieur fillon qui a
redemandé en fait ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'il le fait il a
redemandé des comptes la transparence
des comptes de l'ump à monsieur copé qui
d'ailleurs lui a fait répondre loup lui
a répondu qu il était bien d'accord pour
la transparence de ses comptes
est ce que tout ça cette nature à
remettre le bazar dans votre partie ya
je crois qu'on peut employer un auto
parce que ça a été le bazar ah bon ah
oui ça a été le bazar groupe
parlementaire ça aussi c'était unis pas
demandeur de transparence avait roulé
sur c'est tout à fait légitime et
d'ailleurs les comptes des partis sont
parfaitement transparent vous savez
c'est il ya la commission des
financements de la vie publique qui
contrôle qui peut rendre public tout ce
qu'elle veut bon et on ne peut lui
refuser aucun document les comptes sont
certifiés par deux commissaires aux
comptes indépendants
voilà donc moi je moi je suis pour que
tout se à titre personnel pour que tous
ceux qui veulent avoir accès aux comptes
puissent avoir accès aux billets aussi
une commission ad-hoc au sein même de
votre parti qui est chargé justement de
vérifier les comptes
oui à boissezon l explication interne
bon non mais mais après s'il doit y
avoir des débats sur les sur les comptes
il ya des choses qu'ils veulent je
reviens sur lesquels la question du
début
il ya un risque on voir de guerre
interne si vous changez rien vous me
demandez aux protagonistes des guerres
des guerres du passé
vous êtes vigueur mais je suis pas dans
la tête des uns des autres moi ça ne
m'intéresse pas à te faire de la
politique comme ça mais d'expulser ça
m'intéresse pas du tout voilà ce qui
m'intéresse aujourd'hui c'est le débat
d'idées c'est des transgressions
intellectuelle c'est comment comment on
peut gouverner notre pays dans l'état où
il se trouve
comment on peut affronter toutes les
crises auxquelles il est confronté
ranger l'alternance on peut changer à
tout moment pour changer notre façon de
faire de la politique et le contenu de
nos politiques
est-ce qu'on va continuer avec la
politique économique absurde que que
l'on mène aujourd'hui mais qu'on a mené
pendant des décennies je fais une
parenthèse sur les cinq ans passés
puisque pendant cinq ans on a
essentiellement affronter une crise sans
précédent est plutôt plutôt bien que mal
grâce à nicolas sarkozy mais à part
cette période là on est enfermé dans ce
qu'on appelait jadis la pensée unique
lorsque monsieur philippe séguin appelé
le minix social dans cette espèce de
ronan semant des renoncements politique
devant devant l'économie bon est-ce
qu'on va continuer ça ça ça m'intéresse
avec l'europe telle qu'elle est
politicien sur le programme est
justement sur le programme
c'est ce dont vous êtes en train de
parler la trame de préparer tout ça
programme d'alternance vous par exemple
monsieur guaino vous comment vous
apportez votre pierre à l'édifice
mais moi j'aurai voient proposer ben
vous vient de chez vous je propose je
parle
voilà ma pierre à l'édifice je sais pas
trop ce que c'est que cet édifice dans
la vème république vous savez c'est le
candidat à l'élection présidentielle qui
décide du programme de gouvernement
c'est toujours pareil ce qui est vrai de
dire alors que l'ump n'a pas à faire
honnêtement le président soit élu
zuma temps d'avoir un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle les scénarii
façon disais tout à l'heure à propos du
gouvernement le président c'est le
président qui détermine la politique de
la france même si dans la constitution
du csel promise c'est le président bon
et puis si le candidat à la
présidentielle qui détermine le
programme de gouvernement et le
programme d'alternance c'est ainsi ça a
toujours aimé les voies de la situation
de
habitation et j'ai entendu françois
fillon il ya deux jours dire que l'ump
devait se préparer à toute éventualité
de mam je sais pas si tu as aussi elle
dort se prépare à toute éventualité ça
veut dire que nous sommes appelés à
réfléchir ensemble mais en acceptant
notre diversité sens qu'aujourd'hui y
ait une façon très efficace de de faire
la synthèse la synthèse elle viendra au
moment où nous aurons un candidat mais
que nous ayons un débat d'idées nous
l'avons que nous discutions nous
discutons en revanche l'idée de confier
comme ça a été fait il ya quelques il ya
quelques mois à un comité de dix sages
qui sont dont on ne sait pas d'où ils
tiennent leur sagesse le soin de décrire
un décret dans le dos programme pour
pour l'ump
ça c'est absurde et d'ailleurs moi j'ai
dit que je ne me sentais pas engagé mais
j'ai vu que ni françois barois ni alain
juppé ne se sentait non plus engagé
c'est le genre d'exercice que les partis
font toujours mais qui donc clients pad
qui n'ont pas de portée
ils n'ont pas de portée pratique nous
devons ce que pour l'instant signe déjà
nous arrivions à réfléchir tous ensemble
une somme à révision et à faire de notre
diversité de notre diversité qui est
grande
oui on va le voir au dessus de notre
diversité est une richesse
et bien ce serait déjà alors très bien
on va voir votre diversité sur l'europe
juste un petit mot que dit c'est mission
impossible
pour manuel valls est ce que vous pensez
que il pourrait y avoir une dissolution
avant la fin du quinquennat mais ça
dépend du prix situation soit vous
d'accord sauf qu'avec or vous ne
souhaitez pas je pense que si on regarde
si on a si on a une dissolution dans un
quinquennat ça voudra dire que les
choses ont vraiment très mal et que nos
institutions sont dans un piteux état
merci merci beaucoup nadège valeur
perrine tarneaud donc arriver on va
évoquer justement l'un des grands débats
au sein de l'ump mais comme de tout
parti de tous les partis c'est bien sûr
l'enjeu européen qui vous motive
d'ailleurs particulièrement on l'a
compris henri guaino attendus
c'est à vous dans un instant mais
d'abord il faut expliquer ce qui se
passe
avec l'ump qui espère bien sûr je vais
juste vous dire quelque chose pour finir
ce débat en transition mais oui c'est
disent certains de mes amis avec disait
tout va bien une victoire éclatante oui
c'est une grande victoire électorale
mais faut pas se tromper les français on
manifesté leur rejet à la fois et
fortement du gouvernement et de la
majorité parce qu'ils sont au pouvoir
mais ils ont aussi marqué leur défiance
vis-à-vis de toute la classe politique
sur et et nous avons nous avons devant
nous un défi considérable
voilà qui n'est pas seulement le défi du
gouverneur ceci est quelque chose est
sûre on assiste à une confrontation des
idées à l'ump sur la question européenne
je fais court
samia de sheer il n'y a pas dans la
marque même de l'engagement de l'ump de
doute sur la nécessité d'avoir une
europe plus forte une europe forte
oui mais laquelle la question n'est
toujours pas tranchée à l'ump il pension
saint-janvier henri guaino ancien
conseiller de nicolas sarkozy adresse
une lettre au patron de l'ump
ils protestent alors contre
l'investiture d'alain lamassoure comme
tête de liste aux européennes en
ile-de-france alain lamassoure un pro
européen convaincu
à l'opposé du discours eurosceptiques
d'henri guaino henri guaino il est tout
seul il n'y a personne derrière lui et
donc moi je vais pas passer mon temps à
parler d'un type qui est tout seul
un débat que la présidence du parti
s'est bien gardée d'arbitré jusqu'ici
aujourd'hui le mp n'a pas de ligne en
matière de construction européenne et en
matière de projets européens
elle reste écartelée entre la primauté
aux états nations et les partisans des
états unis d'europe qui sont des
héritiers du centre droit venu de feu
l'udf des querelles balayée par la tête
des listes en ile de france
il assure que désormais l'ump à un
projet clair pour l'europe
nous allons mettre au point demain
mercredi nous allons finaliser le projet
européen de l'ump sur lequel nous
travaillons depuis maintenant deux mois
avec tous les dirigeants de l'ump
alors il y aura toujours quelques francs
tireurs qui seront hostiles ou courant
des idées personnelles
c'est très bien meilleur une position
générale une campagne axée sur l'europe
de la défense de l'énergie mais aussi
vague bleue marine aubry
jeux sur le thème de l'immigration dite
choisi d'une europe qui maîtrise ses
frontières voilà perrine est avec nos
penseurs perrine tarneaud question qui
brûle de répondre qu'est ce que vous
êtes vraiment tout seul isolé à l'ump
sur votre position soit pas du tout mais
je crois que monsieur lamassoure connais
très mal l'ump puisque depuis un certain
temps oui mais comme il passait il a
passé son temps à bruxelles ce qui est
d'ailleurs tout à fait honorable
puisqu'il était député européen mais je
ne fais pas le cas vous savez moi ça
fait 30 ans que j'appartiens à cette
famille politique en tout cas à son
comme sa composante la plus importante
qui s'appelait jadis le rpr j'ai
contribué modestement à l'élection de
deux présidents de la république donc à
l'ump je suis chez moi
mais chez moi je dis ce que j'ai envie
de dire voilà non mais donc je me sens
pas tout seul jeu depuis depuis que j'ai
été élu et je le faisais déjà avant je
sillonne la frange rencontre des
militants je rencontre des élus que dont
beaucoup dans certains jeux tout je
connais depuis très longtemps j'ai pas
l'impression d'être tout seul
nikon et permettez nicolas sarkozy avait
eu l'intelligence de vouloir réconcilier
la france du oui et la france du non
comme le disait et il cherchait avait
cherché à dépasser cette contradiction
bon là on n'est plus dans le dépassement
de la tour contradiction on nous sort
monsieur lamassoure qui incarne et après
tout il sait très respectable il ya peu
de gens qui incarne quelque chose en
politique lui il incarne quelque chose
de c'est très simple c'est que c'est
il incarne l'europe d'aujourd'hui celle
qui est en train de se faire c'est un
peu plus personne ne veut je n'avais pas
dit vous me dis très clairement
aujourd'hui je ne soutiendrai pas la
campagne de monsieur lamassoure monsieur
lamassoure est armé
sur ça ça vous regarde pas je mettrai je
mettrai pas un bulletin à son nom ça je
peux vous le dire dès aujourd'hui ça
peut faire le buzz qu'on voudra je ne
voterai pas pour l'incarnation d'une
ligne qui est à l'opposé dont seulement
de ce que je pense mais de ce que je
crois être l'intérêt de mon pays
mais c'est pourtant celle ci jackie va
être retenu par à l'usb semaine ça va
être un projet de la sélection lui parle
on n'est pas chez staline on n'est pas
au parti communiste
on n'est pas au front national non plus
hein c'est pas personne n'est
propriétaire c'est moi je suis un esprit
libre je me suis engagé à partir des
convictions qui sont les miennes sur
l'intérêt de mon pays
voilà et je préfère j'aime dans le futur
projet alors pour l'instant connecter ce
n'est pas le projet mais vous savez de
la politique c'est des idées et une
incarnation d'abord ont choisi par un
candidat avant d'avoir choisi un projet
là on a fait le contraire
bon ça je suis totalement actif à ce
genre de ce genre de méthode bon
monsieur l'occurrence ans parce que
d'alain lamassoure
il aurait été nommé il y aurait été
désigné comme second soit là sur la
liste après tout ça vous a droit à la
diversité mais là on le met en tête de
lice la liste la plus importante
enfin la prévenue savait garder la main
sur ses terres dès le matin européen
sortons et qu'elle a effectué plusieurs
mandats aussi au parlement remportant
aussi voulu de s'appuyer sur cette
expertise là moi je sais qu'il ya
beaucoup de hans où des ondes versé les
rues de rire en 2d ça n'aurait eu aucune
signification politique et il aurait été
reconduit au parlement et tout le monde
aurait été contents ils auraient pu
faire la preuve de son expertise
mais moi je vais vous dire ma conviction
la plus profonde je ne cesserai de le
répéter dans les semaines qui viennent
ça ne peut pas continuer comme ça alors
ça ne peut pas voilà et si si quelqu'un
veut faire campagne en disant que ça
continue que ça va continuer comme ça je
donne rendez vous ceux qui font cette
campagne le soir des élections
européennes
disons que je pense qu'on ne peut pas
compter bien sûr yard mardi
non tout le monde le dit pas monsieur
les autres avec convaincu reconnaissait
fin il y en a il y en a beaucoup qui
reconnaissent les a peut pas continuer
comme ça qu'il faut que ça change du
tout au tout et puis à des gens qui vous
explique on va changer à la marge que
menace qu'en fera la même politique que
monsieur hollande voix et avec les mêmes
résultats de l'échec programmé aux
élections
si drogba et on tirera les leçons le
soir mais pas aujourd'hui nous avons un
problème en france c'est que le déficit
nous sommes sous surveillance une
surveillante directement est ce que vous
en pensez
est ce que vous attendez de françois
hollande qu'il essaye de négocier avec
bruxelles avec la commission européenne
un bon moyen
moi j'attends d'eux le président de la
république française et du gouvernement
français qu'il fasse preuve d'audace
parce que non seulement l'europe ne peut
plus continuer comme ça mais la
situation de la france non plus non plus
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'ont dit les
français mais ça veut dire que la
commission rappelle les garder l'image
des choses intéressantes en europe et
dans le monde d'ailleurs un des des gens
qui ont cru de l'audace il y en a il y
en a au japon il ya une défaillance été
payés en euros des clients ont fait des
efforts du trader et qui connaissent un
retour 300 oui bien sûr nous sommes tous
assis mais si tu sais non c'est une
blague sa mission elle a fonctionné en
violant tous les traités tous les
traités elle a su faire mais c'est pas
là vous n'êtes pas sarkozy qui a
entraîné ses homologues européens à un
moment où la crise est établi dans tout
le monde tout le monde s'est dit oh la
la c'est celle en tout ce qui était
sacré toutes les tables de la loi ont
été au départ et en déduit dois faire je
peaufine île de danse effectivement que
françois hollande ne me laissait pas
finir bon voilà il se passe quelque
chose en europe d'intéressant c'est ce
que fait monsieur renzi en italie on va
voir ce que ça donne mais ça c'est une
place est une sas et de l'audace
ça c'est l' envie de ne pas continuer
toujours sur le même chemin dans la même
ornière
on verra si réussie la politique
italienne face à valence et la
croissance et ses filiales se filer les
déficits
oui mais ça c'est extraordinaire vous
êtes dans des catégories mentales c'est
c'est intenable
non c'est intenable c'est ça de la pire
façon de faire et de la politique et de
l'économie
extraordinaire à l'économie on peut
raconter n'importe quoi n'importe quoi
et on en a toujours raison c'est extra
c'est le seul domaine on peut raconter
mais là je comprends pas ce que vous
avez fait
sur indices est simple c'est c'est de
retrouver la croissance du chômage de
sortir mon pays de l'ornière et il dit
voilà je bien pleins de 100 milliards
sur la table alors on peut discuter sur
la pertinence mais s'intéresse à 190
milliards de remboursement de ce que
l'état doit aux entreprises 10 milliards
de baisses d impôts et porte à porte ce
projet il ya une audace il ya un vrai
projet on peut le critiquer mais au
moins au moins aussi failli signer
aujourd'hui un tarissement on va essayer
de changer vous retrouvez passé de tesla
dans l'action européenne telle qu'elle
est portée au niveau au niveau de la
france mais lorsque sarkozy l'avait un
peu tiré un peu d'audace on a laissé le
grand espoir il n'a aucune capacité à
s'imposer au niveau européen françois
l'auteur dont elle n'a pas ici je sais
pas si on a la capacité il n'a pas
essayé et deezer est orienté l'europe
c'est comme monsieur jospin on avait
écrit croissance dans le dans traité
d'amsterdam il avait réorienté l'europe
les blagues autre chose je voulais vous
parler d'eux mêmes c'est très important
va pas continuer comme ça et ce qui va
se jouer dans les élections européennes
c'est pas c'est pas laissez pas leurrer
c'est pas tellement le nombre de députés
que chacun d'abba obtenir c'est la
position c'est la position de chacun
face à l'europe
le jour où il a gouverné est ce qu'on
continue comme ça la question est toute
simple est ce qu'on continue comme ça
pour moi monsieur lamassoure paillard
j'ai la plus grande estime et qui équipe
représente sans doute à lui tout seul
toute ma famille politique il est le
visage de la continuité
moi je me le contrat de cette continuité
je voulais vous parler du mariage gay en
grande bretagne je voulais faire vous
faire voir cette photo est celle du
bonheur en angleterre ce week-end c'est
le premier mariage gay qui a été célébré
là bas on va voir sans doute la photo
apparaître non la voit pas et voilà le
bonheur anglais pourquoi pas selon vo
henri guaino la réforme est passée sans
contestation vous n'auriez pas eu
beaucoup de succès en angleterre comme
opposants au mariage gay et je n'en sais
rien ce que je sais c'est que beaucoup
de beaucoup de dangers qui nous guettent
de là bas sont déjà allés faire
consommer c'est à dire que on peut déjà
faire de la gpa amp déjà tous déjà faire
de la pma de façon plus large qu'en
france et que donc l'enjeu n'était pas
le même
tout ça avec la valmont savater d'avis
mais j'ai écouté moi j'suis pas anglais
voilà je suis pas anglais il ya des pays
déjà où il ya des états aux états unis
où on va devant les tribunaux pour
savoir si le le le
l'intérêt de l'enfant doit primer sur
celui du contrat le contrat de la mère
porteuse ou linverse bien moi je veux
pas vivre simplement dans une société où
les choses se passent ainsi c'est tout
moi je suis jean s'est elle aussi
réunion c'est aussi l'union européenne
celle des unions gays
je ne sais pas comment on fait ça
n'arrivera que libertés avec la rien du
tout les droits
on roule non c'est pas si pas un droit
le mariage est une institution et c'est
une institution non pas privé mais
sociale qui existe depuis qu'il existe
des sociétés organisées elle a pour but
de mettre de l'ordre dans la filiation
je sais j'étais parfaitement d'accord et
depuis longtemps pour qu'on fasse un
contrat d'union civile
en revanche je touchais à l'affiliation
à travers le mariage et mais un désordre
dans la société et est renversée valeurs
qui permettent de vivre ensemble d'une
manière que je trouve extrêmement drôle
sans que ces questions de société ont
pesé dans le scrutin municipal a
beaucoup beaucoup et pas seulement à
cause de la question elle-même et de la
manière dont on s'y est pris c'est à
dire de la façon dont le gouvernement a
fait passer ses réformes en méprisant
totalement tous ceux qui n'étaient pas
d'accord avec lui tous ceux dont sarthe
et la conscience en n'essayant pas de
discuter pas trouvé de consensus
et ça c'est c'est la pire des choses
depuis le début d'ailleurs ce
gouvernement c'est chine
cegid a creusé des fractures terrible et
bien cette fracture là elle est très
profonde et très profonde
c'est aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
perrine merci henri guaino la semaine
prochaine notre invité sur un gérard
larcher et pérenno reparlera la de
l'alternance annoncé aux seniors pour
mois de septembre
un autre rendez vous électoral de
l'année a très vite